في عمان يشمل اعلان وزاره الاقتصاد عن
برنامج التنميه الخاص بمحافظه الداخليه
يشمل تنفيذ
47 مشروعا بقيمه تقارب 10 ملايين ريال
عماني حيث يشكل اعلان المشاريع الجديده
دفعه نحو تعزيز اللامركزيه واضافه للبنيه
الاساسيه والتي تاتي في اطار المشروعات
ذات البعد الاجتماعي والعائد الاقتصادي
من مسقط ينظم العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
عبد الرحمن مرحبا في النشره الرابعه من
الرياض عبد الرحمن ما الذي رصدته اثناء
تواجدودك في عمان حول ما يخص برنامج
التنميه الخاص بم بمحافظه الداخليه وكذلك
الحديث عن المشارع المشاري عفوا الجديد
يعني اللي قبل قليل في الخبر اعلن عن تنفي
47 مشروعا منها بقيمه تقارب 10,000,000
ريال
فعلا نايف اخر زياره صحفيه الى سلطنه عمان
كانت تقريبا قبل اربع سنوات زرت مسقط هذه
المره المشهد تغير بشكل كبير مشاريع عديده
همم ايضا في عدد من المحافظات الموجوده
هنا في سلطنه عمان همم بالتزامن مع العيد
الوطني العماني 52 تم الاعلان ايضا عن
مشاريع عشره مشاريع تنمويه بقيمه 750
مليون ريال همم مليار عماني تقريبا يعني
ما يقارب اكثر من اثنين مليار همم دولار
امريكي 950 مليون ريال عماني سادع زميلي
وليد ياخذ لكم جوله في هذا المكان هو احد
المشاريع الجديده النوعيه في العاصمه
العمانيه مسقط كما نشاهد هناك يعني شقق
سكنيه ايضا ابراج ومكاتب وايضا مقرات لبعض
الشركات العالميه اذا ما تحدثنا باللغه
الارقام نايف المشاريع العشره الوطنيه
اللي تم اعلانها قبل ايام قليله متوزعه من
اكثر من قطاع الصناعات التحويليه
البتروكيماويات التنقيب عن النفط بالاضافه
الى السياحه والصناعات التحويليه اذا ما
تحدثنا عن مصنع خاص للكربون سيكون في
محافظه شمال الباطن ايضا هناك محطه تحليه
للمياه في محافظه جنوب الشرقيه ايضا هناك
مصنع للامونيا في محافظه صلاله بقيمه 178
مليون ريال همم عماني ايضا هناك حرص على
موضوع الامن الغذائي في سلطنه عمان هناك
مزرعه ضخمه جدا
للدواجن بالشراكه مع احد الشركات
اليابانيه بقيمه 26 مليون ريال عماني في
محافظه الظاهره ايضا مشروع بساط الذي يرفع
الانتاج تقريبا اضعاف ثلاثه من 500 برميل
نفط يوميا الى حوالي 55 همم الف برميل
يوميا في محافظه الوسطى ايضا كما نشاهد
هذا المشروع همم النوعي في اممم العاصمه
العمانيه مسقط هناك حرس كبير ايضا على
تحقيق جوده الحياه في المشاريع العقاريه
الجديده فيما يتعلق بالمقاهي والمطاعم
والخدمات والبنيه التحتيه يوم امس كنا في
مشروع جديد سكني في لواء اليوم نحن في
مسقط ايضا مشروع عقاري جديد وايضا نشاهد
جميع مستمتع بالاجواء نايف خاصه الان مع
نهايه شهر نوفمبر الشتاء بدا بالدخول الى
سلطنه عمان فاجواء جميله جدا ومشاريع
مستمره وحرص كبير من الحكومه على همم
جيده يا رب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله يرزقنا هنا في عمان لكن
الامطار لسه ما في امطار لكن ربما الايام
المقبله يكون هناك حاله مطريه فا فعلا
المشهد تغير في عمان وهناك حرص كبير من
الشركات العقاريه والشركات الوطنيه على
تقديم مشاريع نوعيه تنمويه تمص المواطن
بالدرجه الاولى وايضا تحقق
شفناها
مباشره
في السلطنه مشاريع كبيره وكبيره يعني وهذا
احد المشاريع ايضا همم اللي انت خرجت
اليوم لتتحدث عنها المسقط انا اشكرك كثير
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل
العربيه مسقط عبد الرحمن حسين